Il a eu 20 points de suture à la main à cause de ce jeu
Sa moyenne générale a baissé de 6 points à cause de ce jeu
Et aujourd'hui, 9 ans après, il fait une vidéo pour parler de ce jeu
Déjà, je vais vous expliquer ce que c'est Dofus parce-que vous avez peut-être pas joué à Dofus dans votre vie
Dofus est un MMORPG français sorti en 2000 *rires*
Dofus est un MMORPG français sorti en 2004
Comme dans tous RPG, tu commences le jeu par une création de personnages et tu as le choix parmi 12 classes
Le but est ensuite de péter la g*eule à un maximum de monstres et de combats au tour par tour de manière à gagner de l'XP et à atteindre le niveau maximum qui est le niveau 200
Mais pour pas être une énorme m*rde, faudrait aussi que tu gères bien ton équipement, équipement que tu pourrais obtenir directement contre les monstres
Ou alors que tu pourras fabriquer grâce aux ressources que tu auras obtenues contre les monstres
Alors, pourquoi j'parle de Dofus maintenant, parce-que c'est le JEU de mon enfance et y'a pas longtemps, ils ont sorti un serveur mono-compte
J'aurais pas dû jouer, j'passe ma vie à ça parce-que j'ai l'impression de re... d'avoir 12 ans de nouveau
J'ai même fait un live sur ma chaîne Twitch sur Dofus dans lequel j'ai looté euh... une coiffe et une cape bouftou dans le même combat
Autant vous dire que ma réaction était digne de SQUEEZIE 2007
OOH OH !
Ha Ha Ha !
Le but de cette vidéo, c'est de raconter aux gens, aux anciens joueurs et euh, aux gens qui ont jamais joué au jeu, des anecdotes extrêmement COOL à propos d'ce jeu
Me concernant, j'ai 3 anecdotes...
... à propos d'ce jeu
La 1ère, vous la connaissez tous, à l'époque Dofus quand... ça me fait rire, c'est tellement con
À l'époque, quand t'étais en combat dans Dofus et qu'tu fermais et relançais le jeu
T'avais forcément perdu le combat
BREF, vous savez ce qui s'est passé
Mon frère a éteint le PC de force parce-que c'était à lui d'aller sur l'ordi
J'ai ragé et tapé dans un cadre, 20 points de suture, on en parle plus
2ème anecdote
J'avais un meilleur ami à l'époque
Comme tout le monde a un meilleur ami
Quand il a 11 ans, avec qui se confier, lui parler de sa 1ère amoureuse
Et généralement ce meilleur ami, tu lui confies ton compte Dofus pour qu'il emmène ton perso avec le sien quand tu ne peux pas jouer
Et un jour, j'étais chez ma grand-mère
Je rentre avec ma belle paire de TN neuve à mes pieds
Je lance Dofus et que vois-je ?
Je suis nu, je n'ai plus mon équipement...
Je ne comprend pas
Je contacte alors mon meilleur ami
Et il m'ignore totalement
Mathieu... j'me souviens de cette anecdote
Pendant 1h, je ne comprend pas ce qu'il m'arrive...
... enfin, mon ami me MP en me disant...
"C'était une blague, HaHa"
Très grosse blague, qui m'a valu un traumatisme
Il m'a alors rendu mon Abracaska, qui était un objet de m*rde d'ailleurs, mais j'étais content parce-que j'étais un noob
Et j'étais l'homme le plus heureux du monde
3ème anecdote
Un jour, quelqu'un vendait, ce qu'on appelle
Une Gelamu
Je l'ai alors contacté, lui disant que j'étais intéressé
On a lancé l'échange, il a mis un Gelamu et ce gros CON
Au lieu d'attendre que je mette des Kamas
Il a accepté immédiatement
Donc j'ai accepté l'échange, j'ai alors reçu une Gelamu gratuitement et ce joueur n'a rien reçu en retour
J'ai alors fait c'que tout le monde fait, quand il vient d'arnaquer quelqu'un
J'ai changé de map *rires*
Et ce joueur m'envoyait des messages... encore et encore
Il était si triste d'avoir perdu son amulette si précieuse
Et j'ai été pris de remords et je lui ai rendu son amulette
Gratuitement *applaudissements*
Merci à tous, j'peux vous dire que c'est arrivé 4 fois maximum dans l'histoire de Dofus, un truc comme ça
4ème anecdote, pardon que j'ai oublié
Et celle-là m'a value, une bonne leçon de ma maman
Dofus est un jeu gratuit mais tu peux payer 5€/mois pour avoir accès à toutes les zones
Donc quand ton perso commence à avoir un certain niveau
Tu vas être obligé de payer l'abonnement pour pouvoir accéder aux zones qui vont te permettre de continuer d'évoluer
Le problème, c'est qu'à l'époque, on était tous mineurs, on avait pas de carte bleue
Donc pour acheter de l'abonnement, il y avait 2 solutions
Soit tu achetais une... paysafe card, j'crois ça s'appelait, dans un tabac du coin
Soit tu prenais le téléphone de ta maman et tu appelais un numéro payant
Et grâce au code qu'on te donnait, tu pouvais avoir une semaine d'abonnement
Bien entendu
Tout le monde faisait ça
J'avais FAIT 30 CODES, mais je ne savais PAS que c'était payant
J'ai alors reçu un coup de fil
Et j'ai compris que pendant le mois à venir, je n'allais plus trop pouvoir jouer à Dofus
Y'a un truc dont j'aimerais qu'on se souvienne tous et qu'on en parle un petit peu
Les arnaques !
Dofus, c'est le seul jeu au monde où les joueurs passent plus de temps à mettre au point des arnaques... qu'à jouer
C'est vraiment n'importe quoi
Les fameux CODES qui te faisaient avoir du hors-forfait mais qui permettaient de gagner une semaine d'abonnement
Et ben, des joueurs voulaient t'les acheter, ces codes
Ils mettaient alors le message
"Achète code audio, no noob test avant"
Bien évidemment, certains joueurs s'amusaient à faire semblant de vendre des codes
Mais ils en vendaient pas
Le mec te donnait les Kamas, mais toi tu donnais pas le code
Qu'est-ce que tu faisais ?
Tu changeais de map *rires*
C'était l'arnaque la plus répandue parce-qu'elle était VITALE pour les joueurs, avoir un abonnement, c'était vitale donc tout le monde essayait de douiller un peu tout le monde
Bref, c'est le jeu, il y avait vraiment le MOINS de confiance entre les joueurs, mais de la planète !
Au tout début de Dofus, il n'y avait pas le système d'échange
Tu pouvais pas échanger d'objets avec des joueurs
Du coup, les joueurs avaient trouvé un moyen de s'échanger des trucs
C'est qu'ils allaient sur une même map, ils se mettaient de part et d'autre de la map et chacun posait par terre, l'objet qu'il voulait échanger à l'autre
Puis les 2 allaient chercher l'objet que l'autre avait mis par terre
C'était sans compter sur la ruse de ces c*nnards de joueurs de Dofus
Certaines personnes malhonnêtes, appelaient un ami à eux en renfort et lui disaient de se cacher dans un buisson ou derrière un arbre
Sur la map
Voilà
Et quand le mec lâchait l'objet par terre
Ton pote le prenait immédiatement
En vrai pour remédier à ce problème, il y avait un mode transparence dans Dofus, qui permettait de voir à travers tout les décors
Hein, notamment de voir s'il y a un gros c*nnard se cachait dans le but de voler ton objet
Hmmm~
*clic*
Mais LES nouveaux joueurs, il savaient pas ça
Donc il activait pas le mode, il sait même pas que ça existait
Les mecs étaient tellement prêt à tout pour être riche, qu'ils devenaient même mentaliste
Ils disaient sur une place publique
"Je vous donne 10% de vos kamas, lancez échange !"
Toi tu disais : "OH !"
Le mec, il donne 10% de nos kamas, mais il est adorable !
Et tu étais si pressé de gagner ces 10% de kamas en PLUS pour ta bourse
Que tu oubliais de retirer la TOTALITÉ des kamas que tu avais mis dans l'échange
Donc en réalité, tu r'sortais de cet échange
Au lieu d'avoir 10% de kamas en plus
T'avais 10% de tes kamas tout court
Qui est resté dans l'inventaire
Ok, pour vous expliquer l'arnaque suivante, laissez-moi vous faire un petit rappel
Dans Dofus, tu lootes des objets contre des monstres
Et parmi ces objets, se trouve le Gelano
Aaaah~ *Voix de saints*
C'est un anneau qui donne un point d'action
C'est OUF, un point d'action
Dans Dofus, il est possible de forgemager les objets
C'est-à-dire d'améliorer leurs stats, voire même de leur créer de nouvelles stats
Tu pouvais donc forgemager le Gelano pour qu'en plus de te donner un point d'action, il te donne... un point de mouvement
Sauf que quand ça a foiré, le Gelano ne te donnait... plus rien !
Il perdait alors toute sa valeur, mais certaines personnes ont trouvé une technique pour quand même le vendre
Les mecs disaient dans le canal commerce, un canal que tout le monde voit
"Vend Gelano, 50 000 kamas"
C'est un truc qui valait 1 million
Tout le monde faisait : "EUH !"
Mais y'a de l'argent à se faire dis donc
Tout le monde allait sur la map du mec
Lui lançait l'échange et disait "Nan, nan, nan, nan, nan, j'vais pas le donner à un mec au pif comme ça, c'est pas cool"
"J'vais passer en mode marchand et le premier qui l'achète l'aura"
Le mec passait en mode marchand, tu te dépêchais de cliquer sur le Gelano et de cliquer sur "acheter" pour vite l'avoir
Et une fois dans ton inventaire, tu t'apercevais qu'il ne donnait pas de point d'action
*Applaudit* Mais quelle inventivité !
Mais si ces mecs là, avaient mis leur intelligence au service de la science et pas au service des arnaques sur Dofus
Mais mon gars...
Aujourd'hui, on roulerait dans des voitures volantes, c'est sûr !
Une autre arnaque, c'était la toute première que j'ai vécu
C'est vraiment celle-là, qui fait que, d'un coup t'es plus du tout naïf et que tu vas commencer à te méfier de tout le monde
Mais pas ton meilleur pote, qui va te voler ton Abracaska
C'était un matin où il pleuvait dehors, du coup, j'étais sur Dofus
Bon en vrai, j'étais sur Dofus même quand il faisait soleil
J'étais dans la ? comme ça, je zonais, lorsqu'un mec dans le canal commerce a mis
"Vend cape bouftou, 15 000 kamas, mp moi"
Je lui ai alors envoyé un message, en lui disant
"Mec je suis si intéressé"
Je le rejoins, je lance "échange"
Et j'avais pas 15 000 kamas
J'avais que 8000 kamas
Donc j'ai mis 8000, j'ai mis des ressources en lui disant
"Bon mec les ressources tu peux les vendre et au total y'en aura pour 15 000 !"
Il m'a dit "Ok ça marche, t'inquiètes"
Waouh
Il est gentil
Mais dans Dofus et comme dans tout les RPG, t'as pas un inventaire illimité
Des fois, ton inventaire est plein et il faut un peu le vider pour pouvoir euh, recevoir de nouveaux objets et de nouvelles ressources
Et cette personne là, m'a dit
"Atten-tten-ttend j'peux pas accepter l'échange, mon inventaire est plein là, faut que j'te donne 2-3 trucs"
Alors il a mis dans l'échange, 2, 3, 6, 9 trucs, j'étais content
Waouh, une cape bouftou pas chère, plus des ressources, c'est vraiment un mec bien
Mais t'ai-je dis ?
Sauf qu'en faite, la cape bouftou s'était retrouvée tout en bas de l'échange
Et j'ai pas eu le reflexe d'aller voir, en cliquant sur la flèche, en bas de l'échange, si elle était encore là
J'ai cliqué sur "accepter"
Il a cliqué sur "accepter"
J'ai souris devant l'écran
Et en ouvrant mon inventaire, pour équiper la cape bouftou, j'ai découvert que...
Elle n'était pas là
Il l'avait retiré sans que je m'en aperçoive
J'ai alors regardé son perso, me disant
"Nan, il va quand même pas..."
La cape bouftou, p*tain
*bip*
J'espère que cette vidéo vous aura rendu nostalgique, si vous êtes un ancien joueur de Dofus
Que ça vous a donné envie de plonger dans un maintenant, pour dans 10 ans, rejouer à ce jeu
Et sentir à travers vous, un feeling incroyable
Ça m'a fait plaisir d'enfin, vous raconter tout ces trucs à propos de Dofus
J'espère que ça vous aura fait kiffer aussi et j'vous dit À BIENTÔT
J'passe en mode marchant, j'vend Gelano, 50 000 seulement, le 1er qui l'achète, il...
Abonnes-toi :)